Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. All she saw was a merciless sea of black crosses, bearing little strips of stamped tin at all angles across their faces. She could distinguish no order or arrangement in their mass, nothing but a waist-high wilderness as of weeds stricken dead rushing at her. She went forward, moved to the left and the right hopelessly, wondering by what guidance she should ever come to her own. A great distance away there was a line of whiteness.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》节目。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听资格，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。她所看到的只是一片冷酷无情的黑色十字架海洋，它们带着刻有字样的小块马口铁，以各种角度朝向四面八方。她在这一片密密麻麻之中辨别不出任何秩序或排列，除了一片齐腰深、犹如枯死的杂草般向她猛扑过来的荒野之外，什么也看不见。她向前走去，无望地向左又向右移动，琢磨着自己该凭着怎样的指引才能找到亲人的墓碑。在极远处有一排白色的东西。
It proved to be a block of some two or three hundred graves, whose headstones had already been set, whose flowers were planted out, and whose new-sown grass showed green. Here she could see clear-cut letters at the ends of the rows, and referring to her slip, realised that it was not here she must look. That is towards the end of a short story called The Gardener by Rudyard Kipling. And it describes a woman called Helen Turrell, a spinster who has brought up her nephew, who then enlists in the First World War, dies. And that describes her going to one of the war cemeteries that is in the first world war dies and that describes her going to um one of the war cemeteries that is in the process of of being built uh and dominic i know that you're an admirer of that short story because it packs an incredible punch at the end doesn't it for reasons that i'm
原来那是两三百座坟墓的一个方阵，墓碑已经立好，花坛已经种上，新播的草坪泛着绿色。在这里，她可以看到行头末端清晰的字母，对照着手中的纸条，她意识到这里不是她要找的地方。这段话出自鲁德亚德·吉卜林（Rudyard Kipling）的一篇名为《园丁》（The Gardener）的短篇小说尾声。故事讲述了一个名叫海伦·图雷尔（Helen Turrell）的未婚女子，她抚养了自己的侄子，侄子后来在第一次世界大战中参战并牺牲了。这段话描绘了她去参观一处一战战争公墓的情景——而多米尼克，我知道你是这篇短篇小说的崇拜者，因为它在结尾处有着极其震撼的力量，不是吗？原因嘛，我……
not going to explain no people if you haven't read it it's available online it's it's quite short it's i think it's one of the great short stories ever written. I couldn't agree more, Tom. It's funny because you said to me you were going to go in on The Gardener, Kipling's short story from 1925, to start the podcast. And I had been thinking, would I mention The Gardener in the podcast? And I thought, I won't go into it in case Tom hasn't read it. And then I'll have to do all the carrying with it.
不打算解释。没错，大家如果没读过，网上可以搜到，它非常短，我认为这是有史以来最伟大的短篇小说之一。我完全赞同，汤姆。说来也巧，你之前跟我说，你要把吉卜林1925年的短篇小说《园丁》作为播客的开场。而我一直在想，我要不要在播客里提一下《园丁》？后来我想，还是别提了，万一汤姆没读过，那我岂不是得一个人撑起整个话题。
And I might start crying. And that would be really... Do you know, Tom, I read it and then i'll have to do all the carrying with it and i might start crying and that would be really do you know i i read it uh every every 11th do you remember i do i do i'm not i i don't think i've ever worn a poppy i'm not generally a great one for that kind of stuff right but i do read the gardener because i always want to read it and find out will i manage to read it without welling up at the end yeah Yeah. As yet, no. Yeah. It's such a, for people who think that Kipling is all the jungle book and sort of imperial jingoism, if you read this one short story
而且我可能会哭出来。那可就真的……你知道吗，汤姆，我读了这篇小说，然后我得一个人撑起整个话题，而且我可能会哭出来，那可就真的……你知道吗，我读过它，呃，每个每年的11月——你还记得吗？我记得，我真的记得。我不是那种……我好像从来没戴过虞美人花，我通常对那种东西不太感冒，对吧？但我确实会读《园丁》，因为我总是想读一遍，看看自己能不能在不眼眶湿润的情况下读到结尾。是的，是的。到目前为止，还没有成功。是的。对于那些认为吉卜林的全部作品就是《丛林奇谭》和某种帝国沙文主义的人来说，如果你读了这篇短篇小说……
and it will only take you, it won't even take you an hour, it will utterly dispel everything you thought about Kipling. Because Kipling, of course, had lost his son, Tom, hadn't he? John, at Loose in 1915. And he was, Kipling had pulled strings to get him into the army and then lost his son and the grief to get him into the army and then lost
它只会花掉你一点时间，甚至用不了一个小时，就会彻底颠覆你对吉卜林的全部看法。因为吉卜林当然失去了他的儿子，汤姆，对吧？约翰，于1915年在卢斯（Loos）阵亡。而且吉卜林曾通过走后门才让儿子参军，随后却失去了儿子，那种悲痛……曾通过走后门才让儿子参军，随后却失去了……
his son and the grief stayed with him yeah for the rest of his and the guilt I suppose to some extent for the rest of his life and and I think that we're talking about obviously Remembrance Day um the honesty it's all that kind of stuff uh because today the day that this episode is going out is the 11th of November um and one of the challenges, obviously, for people was to deal with the scale of the loss and the scale of the grief. And I think often in terms of literature, it's a struggle for people.
儿子，这种悲痛一直伴随着他，是的，伴随着他的余生，我想某种程度上还有内疚感，伴随着他的余生。我想，既然我们显然在谈论阵亡将士纪念日（Remembrance Day），呃，那种坦诚，诸如此类的事情——因为今天，也就是本期节目播出的这一天，正好是11月11日——对人们来说，显而易见的挑战之一，就是如何应对巨大规模的伤亡和巨大规模的悲痛。我认为，在文学层面上，这往往是人们的一场挣扎。
But I think the Kipling story is, I think it's the greatest work of literature specifically on this topic. I think there are two great works of literature, Tom, aren't there? There's Kipling's short story and there's a new book, I think. Isn't there? Oh, yes. Sorry.
但我认为吉卜林的这篇小说，我认为它是专门针对这个主题最伟大的文学作品。汤姆，我认为有两部伟大的文学作品，对吧？有一部是吉卜林的短篇小说，还有一本新书，我想。难道不是吗？哦，是的。抱歉。
Dominic. God, here I am. Here I am dwelling on Kipling, who's been long dead. But of course, the top historian has written. Enough of the dead. Yes. Let's cut to the living. Dominic, I gather you have a new book out on the first
多米尼克。天哪，我居然在这里。我居然在这里大谈特谈已经去世很久的吉卜林。不过当然了，这位资深历史学家写过……死者已经够了。没错。让我们直接切入生者。多米尼克，我听说你有一本关于第一次世界大战的新书要出版……
world war i do indeed it's one of my adventures in time series about the first of all and i promise we won't talk about it too much is it very moving so i think i found it quite moving to write it actually i found it genuinely moving and um the first world war is like all wars it's a mosaic of of you know incredibly sort of stirring and emotive individual stories. And writing it for children, I was particularly conscious of that because, of course, the First World War is presented to children as this sort of abyss of suffering. So, yeah, but enough of that.
我的确有一本。这是我的“时间大冒险”（Adventures in Time）系列中关于第一次世界大战的一部——我保证我们不会过多谈论它。这本书很感人吗？实际上，我发现写这本书的过程对我来说挺感人的，我发现它是发自内心地感人。呃，第一次世界大战就像所有战争一样，是由各种（你知道的）极其激动人心和令人感动的个人故事交织而成的一幅马赛克画卷。而为儿童写作时，我对此尤为敏感，因为当然了，第一次世界大战在儿童面前通常被呈现为一种苦难的深渊。所以，好吧，这些就说到这里。
So you can obviously buy it for your children, or you should for Christmas. But we want to talk more broadly, don't we, about the end of the war and how it was remembered. So why don't we, before we get into the remembrance itself, just start, why don't we start sort of on the last day. So, yeah. It's a kind of sequel to the Gary Sheffield episode.
所以你们显然可以为你们的孩子买这本书，或者你们应该在圣诞节时买。但我们想要更广泛地谈谈，不是吗？关于战争的结束以及人们是如何纪念它的。那么，在我们深入探讨纪念活动本身之前，为什么我们不先开始……为什么我们不从最后一天开始呢？所以，好吧。这有点像加里·谢菲尔德（Gary Sheffield）那一集节目的续集。
Yeah. About the Western Front. So the Germans have been, they've launched their great gamble, haven't they? And they've been pushed back and everything's falling apart in Germany. The German revolution has started and they've already sent envoys to the compiain forest to talk to the allies uh and so it's monday the 11th of november we could start i guess we could start at 5 19 in the morning which is when the envoys they've heard sos, right? Yeah, they're politicians. There's, I think, a couple of military guys. They have been sort of sent.
是的。关于西线战场。所以德国人一直在……他们发起了他们那场巨大的豪赌，对吧？他们被逼退了，德国的一切都在分崩离析。德国革命已经爆发，他们已经派遣特使前往贡比涅森林（Compiegne Forest）与盟军谈判。所以现在是11月11日星期克，我想我们可以从清晨5点19分开始，那是特使们……他们听到了SOS信号，对吧？是的，他们是政治家。我想还有几名军人。他们被派了过去。
They have the... The regime is collapsing behind them. So the Kaiser has fled. The Kaiser fled on Saturday night, Sunday morning. To the Netherlands. So it's now Monday. They've discovered, they see from the French Royal Women's newspapers
他们拥有……他们背后的政权正在崩溃。所以德皇已经逃跑了。德皇是在周六晚上、周日早晨逃跑的。逃去了荷兰。所以现在是星期一。他们发现，从法国皇家女性报纸（French Royal Women's newspapers）上看到……
that the Kaiser has abdicated and Germany is in revolution. They've been given a few days to consider the Allies' terms, and they basically decide they have no choice but to accept them. So they gather in Marshal Foch's carriage in this forest, in this forest clearing, very bleary-eyed, just round about dawn, before dawn, I think, and they end up signing the terms that basically say hostilities will cease at 11th of November, i.e. on Monday,
德皇已经退位，德国正处于革命之中。他们被给了几天时间来考虑盟军的条款，他们基本上决定除了接受别无选择。于是他们在黎明时分、拂晓前不久，非常睡眼惺忪地聚集在这片森林、这片森林空地的福煦元帅（Marshal Foch）的车厢里，最终签署了这些条款。条款基本上规定敌对行动将在11月11日，也就是星期一停止……
at 11 o'clock. They have to give a time, obviously, a random time. And so they choose it for the symmetry of it. Yeah, well, also because that will give time for the news to spread across the front. 11, 11, 11. I mean, that's... Yeah, of course. Well, it's not the 11th minute of the 11th hour.
在11点整。当然，他们必须给出一个具体时间，一个随意的时间。所以他们选择这个时间是为了它的对称性。嗯，也是因为这样可以给消息传遍整个前线留出时间。11时11分11秒。我的意思是，那是……是的，当然。嗯，这并不是第11小时的第11分钟。
It's just at 11 o'clock. 11 o'clock? Yeah. Of the 11th day. Of the 11th hour. Yeah, I suppose of the 11th. Yeah. So the weird thing is that the fighting obviously goes on to 11.
它只是在11点整。11点整？是的。在第11天。在第11小时。是的，我想是在第11个……是的。所以奇怪的是，战斗显然一直持续到11点。
Because the French and the Americans in particular don't trust the Germans, right? Well, also there's an inbuilt ratchet, isn't there? I mean, if you're frightened, if you think there's a possibility that the enemy will carry on fighting, then you'll carry on fighting. So it depends slightly where you are on the front. But basically in those few hours, more than 2,000 men are killed. I mean, it's extraordinary to think. Imagine dying at 10 o'clock. And people do die at kind of 10 45 and so
因为法国人和美国人尤其不信任德国人，对吧？嗯，同时这也是一种内置的棘轮效应，不是吗？我的意思是，如果你感到害怕，如果你认为敌人有可能继续战斗，那么你就会继续战斗。所以这在一定程度上取决于你在前线的位置。但基本上在那几个小时里，有两千多人被杀。我的意思是，想起来真不可思议。想象一下在10点钟死去。人们确实在差不多10点45分左右死去……
on so the last the last uh british competent is george ellison from leeds i looked up on wikipedia absolutely top quality research going on here but and but the thing that's interesting about him yeah is that that he had fought at Mons in 1914. Yeah. So he'd done the retreat from Mons. Right to the beginning. He'd fought on the Western Front. He'd survived it.
诸如此类。所以最后一个……最后一个英国阵亡将士是来自利兹（Leeds）的乔治·埃利森（George Ellison）。我在维基百科上查过，这里正在进行绝对高质量的研究。但是，关于他，有趣的地方在于……是的，那就是他曾在1914年的蒙斯（Mons）战役中战斗过。是的。所以他经历过蒙斯撤退。从最开始就在。他在西线战场战斗过。他活了下来。
He survived it. And then he got killed outside Mons. So he'd returned to Mons on the push an hour and a half. That's gutting, isn't it? I mean, there's some really heartbreaking stories. So there's a French guy, Augustine trebuchon and he's a messenger he's from the sort of southwest of france down by the long dock or something and at 10 45 he's given a note by his kind of commanding officer um he says go and give this note to the troops and tell them you know only 15 minutes to go as soon as the clock ticks'll have, there's going to be food for them at the back.
他活了下来。然后他在蒙斯郊外被杀。所以他在推进过程中又回到了蒙斯，就在一个半小时前。这太令人心碎了，不是吗？我的意思是，有一些真正令人心碎的故事。比如有一个法国人，奥古斯丁·特布雄（Augustine Trebuchon），他是一名传令兵，来自法国西南部朗格多克（Languedoc）附近什么的。在10点45分，他接到指挥官递来的一张便条，呃，指挥官说：“把这张便条交给部队，告诉他们（你知道的）只剩15分钟了，一到钟点……后方就会有食物等着他们。
We'll have a big meal. Trebuchon goes off and he's killed. And the note is in his hand. He was shot or something. There's another guy from, there's a guy from Canada, this man called George Price. He's searching houses by a Belgian canal and he's shot by a German sniper.
我们会吃上一顿大餐。”特布雄出发了，然后他牺牲了。便条还握在他的手里。他中弹了还是怎么的。还有另一个人，来自加拿大，这个人叫乔治·普莱斯（George Price）。他在搜查一条比利时运河旁的房屋时，被一名德国狙击手击中了。
And with just minutes minutes minutes to go a nurse nurses come and run to his aid and he dies two minutes before the ceasefire and then the very last is this Henry Gunter yes he's a he's only got himself to blame it's a terrible story so Henry Gunter is a is from Baltimore he's um he had been sergeant, but he's been demoted for bad behavior. I can't remember exactly what the bad behavior was. He's been demoted, and he's desperate to get promoted before the ceasefire, to get his stripes back, basically. So he decides to charge a German machine gun post,
在只剩几分钟、几分钟、几分钟的时候，护士们跑来施救，他在停火前两分钟牺牲了。然后最后一位是亨利·冈特（Henry Gunther）。是的，他只能怪他自己，这是一个极其悲惨的故事。所以亨利·冈特来自巴尔的摩（Baltimore），他曾是一名……他曾是一名中士，但因为表现不佳被降职了。我不记得具体是什么不良表现了。他被降职了，他迫切地想在停火前晋升，基本上是想把军衔条拿回来。所以他决定向一个德国机枪阵地发起冲锋……
and the clock is literally ticking down the seconds. And everybody shouts, stop, stop, you're mad. Yeah. His own stop, stop. You're mad. Yeah. His own side say, stop the Germans wave him away and say, stop, you know, stop coming.
而时钟上的秒针真的在滴答倒计时。所有人都大喊：“停下，停下，你疯了吗？”是的。他自己的一方……停下，停下，你疯了吗？是的。他自己的一方说停下，德国人也挥手让他走开，说：“停下，你知道的，别再过来了。
There's only seconds left. What are you doing? And he just keeps coming because he thinks he'll be promoted and they, they shoot him. And apparently he, he lands in the mud as the, the clocks are. Yeah.
只剩几秒钟了。你在干什么？”他还是不断往前冲，因为他觉得自己会晋升，然后他们……他们开枪打死了他。据说他……随着钟声响起，他倒在了泥地里。是的。
As the bells are sounding. Well, the other story about as the bells are sounding. Well, the other story about as the bells are sounding is the Wilfred Owen story, which I think is probably a little bit apocryphal. So Wilfred Owen has been killed just before, so a few days earlier. But the story goes that it's as the bells are ringing,
随着钟声响起。好吧，关于钟声响起的另一个故事是威尔弗雷德·欧文（Wilfred Owen）的故事，我认为这个故事可能有点虚构。所以威尔弗雷德·欧文在之前不久阵亡了——也就是几天前。但传说正当钟声敲响时……
and I think Shrewsbury... And cheers, everyone's cheering. Yeah, that the postman turns up, opens the gate and comes and knocks on the door and gives his parents the telegram. I think that story has too much symmetry to be true, but it does give you a sense of the sort of, that even amid the celebration,
我想是在什鲁斯伯里（Shrewsbury）……大家都在欢呼，所有人都在欢呼。是的，邮递员出现鸟，打开大门，敲响房门，把电报交给了他的父母。我觉得这个故事的对称性太完美了，不太可能是真的，但它确实让你感受到了一种氛围：即使在庆祝活动之中，
there is this sense of terrible tragedy. Right. And so in the wake of the ceasefire, the armistice, the end of the war, there then comes the question of how do you mark it? How do you commemorate it? Even on the day, people think, I mean. Well, but even before it, I mean, we'll come to that. But I mean, now to us, it seems obvious that you would remember it, that you would commemorate it, that it would be something that you'd kind of swathe in ritual, I suppose.
也存在着一种可怕的悲剧感。没错。因此，在停火、停战、战争结束之后，随之而来的问题是：你该如何纪念它？你该如何缅怀它？甚至在当天，人们就在想，我的意思是……好吧，甚至在此之前，我的意思是，我们会谈到这一点。但我的意思是，对我们现在来说，显而易见的是你会去铭记它，你会去纪念它，它会成为某种你用仪式包裹起来的东西，我想是的。
Yeah. But actually, it's not obvious. Because if you look at the previous great conflict, the Napoleonic Wars, Battle of Waterloo or whatever, it's not commemorated in that way at all. and in fact you know people are going over and yorkshire kind of fertilizer manufacturers are going over and shoveling up the bones which is why there are no bones to be found here at water i think they found i think they found a soldier in 2012 or something and they were digging a car park ready for the uh they're on our fields in yorkshire is that what you're saying they've all they've they all got cleat they've so basically so there was a there was some germans would complain that that british fertilizer companies were kind of going across all the battlefields of europe scooping up all the bones and taking them grinding them up and taking
是的。但实际上，这并不是显而易见的。因为如果你看看以前的那场大冲突——拿破仑战争、滑铁卢战役之类的事情——它根本就不是以这种方式被纪念的。事实上，你知道，人们会过去——约克郡的某种化肥制造商会过去铲起那些骨头，这就是为什么你在滑铁卢这里找不到什么骨头了。我想他们在2012年左右发现了一名士兵的骸骨，当时他们正在为……挖掘停车场，准备……等等，你是说在约克郡的田野里吗？你是这个意思吗？他们都有……所以基本上，有些德国人会抱怨说，英国的化肥公司会横扫欧洲的各个战场，搜刮所有的骨头，把它们带回去，磨碎，然后再带……
them back and selling them to farmers in yorkshire that's a that's a nation of shopkeepers for you there isn't it i mean one man's backers and others commercial fertilizing opportunity and the teeth yeah so even in the american civil war uh people are harvesting teeth uh and uh you know and within you know byron goes when he when he um you know he leaves england and goes on his grand tour across europe he stops off at waterloo um he's a tourist and he's one of a large number of tourists who are visiting it. Yeah. And there is this, it seems to us, incredibly hard-nosed attitude towards casualties.
运回英国，卖给约克郡的农民。这就是所谓的“店主之国”（a nation of shopkeepers）对你们的意义，不是吗？我的意思是，一个人的残骸是另一个人的商业化肥商机，还有牙齿，是的。所以甚至在美国内战中，人们也在收集牙齿……你知道的，拜伦（Byron）在他离开英国前往欧洲进行壮游（grand tour）时，他在滑铁卢停了下来……他是一个游客，他是众多参观滑铁卢的游客之一。是的。在当时，人们对伤亡的态度在我们看来是极其冷酷无情的。
But I'm guessing that the reason why there's such a difference is that armies in the First World War are conscripted armies. And so there's a sense that they're citizen armies. And so it's a nation in arms. So that's kind of radically different, isn it that is different i think there had been a change before that i think the victorian cult of death is obviously part of it the victorian obsession with memorialization and their rituals of mourning and so on um which does mark them out as different from their predecessors i think there had been there have been memorials to the
但我猜之所以会有这么大的不同，是因为第一次世界大战中的军队是征兵制军队。因此，人们有一种感觉，它们是公民军队。所以这是一个全民皆兵的国家。这在根本上是完全不同的，不是吗？确实不同。我认为在此之前就已经发生过变化了。我认为维多利亚时代的死亡崇拜显然是其中的一部分，维多利亚时代对纪念活动的痴迷以及他们的哀悼仪式等等，这使得他们与前代人有所不同。我认为在那之前就已经有纪念活动了……
dead of the crimea and then particularly the big precedent is the Boer War. So there are still a lot of Boer War memorials, you know, in sort of market towns and things across England. So again, there's a sense at that point, I think, that war is becoming both – casualties in war are becoming shocking and something worth noting, but also that they're becoming individual you know so that you want your the names recorded i mean that's definitely the case of the first world war that people did not want the instinct was well we'll just have what we had in previous wars which
克里米亚战争死难者的纪念活动，然后特别重大的先例是布尔战争（Boer War）。所以仍然有很多布尔战争的纪念碑，你知道的，散布在英格兰的各种集镇等地。所以同样地，我认为在那时有一种感觉，即战争正在变成两件事——战争中的伤亡正在变得令人震惊且值得关注，但同时它们也正在变得个体化，你知道的，所以你会希望把他们的名字记录下来。我的意思是，第一次世界大战绝对就是这种情况，人们并不希望……当时的直觉是：嗯，我们将沿用以前战争的做法，
is mass graves so the officers will be will be different but the men will just be in mass graves and there's a general feeling i think that that is intolerable, that so many people have joined up. Some have been conscripted. Some have been volunteers before that. But they're ordinary blokes. They're not professional soldiers, and they deserve better. And that all are equal in death. Well, that's a really interesting thing, isn't it?
也就是集体坟墓。所以军官们会得到不同的对待，但普通士兵只会葬在集体坟墓里。而我认为当时有一种普遍的感受，即这是不可容忍的——那么多人都参军了。有些人是被征兵入伍的。有些人在此之前是志愿者。但他们是普通人。他们不是职业军人，他们理应得到更好的对待。而且所有人在死后都是平等的。嗯，这是一个非常有趣的问题，不是吗？
And that's so – do you know all about this, about the War Graves Commission and all this? Because this is a fascinating story. Well, I know that plans for it get set up before the end of the war, say in 1917, I think. Yeah, I mean, going back- It's Fabian Ware, isn't it? So Fabian Ware is a director of the Rio Tinto Zinc Company. So if you're a conspiracy theorist in the 60s,
这就是——关于战争坟墓委员会（War Graves Commission）和所有这些，你都了解吗？因为这是一个引人入胜的故事。嗯，我知道有关它的计划在战争结束前就已经制定了，大概在1917年吧，我想。是的，我的意思是，追溯到……是法比安·韦尔（Fabian Ware），对吧？法比安·韦尔是力拓锌业公司（Rio Tinto Zinc Company）的董事。所以如果你是60年代的阴谋论者，
you believed that they were the kind of part of the Illuminati or something. Anyway, he's too old to fight in the war, but he goes and I think he's involved with the red cross and immediately i think in 1914 he says well what are we gonna it's killing so many people what are we gonna do and he puts a lot of he talks to sort of bigwigs back home puts a lot of pressure on the government and they set up a graves registration commission and that becomes the imperial war graves commission and that's in 1917 isn't it exactly they have a report what we're going to do.
你可能会相信他们是光照派（Illuminati）之类组织的一部分。不管怎样，他当时年纪太大而无法参军，但他去了前线，我想他参与了红十字会的工作。我记得就在1914年，他立刻说道：“嗯，我们要怎么处理……这场战争夺去了这么多人的生命，我们该怎么办？”他向国内的大人物们施加了很大压力，向政府施压，于是他们成立了一个坟墓登记委员会（Graves Registration Commission），后来演变成了帝国战争坟墓委员会（Imperial War Graves Commission），那是1917年成立的，对吧？绝对是的。他们有一份报告，说明我们要怎么做。
And they say everybody should be, what is it? Whatever their military rank or position of civil life, everybody should have equal treatment in their graves. Now that's quite controversial at the time because a lot of richer families thought that they should have the right to bring their, bring the dead back and bury them in the manorial estate or something. And that's a key decision, isn't it?
他们说每个人都应该——不管他们的军阶或平民生活中的地位如何，所有人在坟墓中都应该受到平等的对待。这在当时引起了相当大的争议，因为许多比较富裕的家庭认为他们有权把亲人的遗体带回来，埋葬在庄园或其他地方。这是一个关键的决定，不是吗？
That everyone will be buried where they died. Yeah, where they died. Same grave. Same grave design. Right. And so when this gets the green light, the Prince of Wales, the future Edward VIII, becomes the president of it.
每个人都将被安葬在他们牺牲的地方。是的，他们牺牲的地方。同样的墓穴。同样的墓碑设计。对。所以当这个方案获得绿灯后，威尔士亲王（未来的爱德华八世）成为了该委员会的主席。
They get in, basically kind of amazing people get involved in it. So they have Britain's absolute top architects. Lutyens, the great imperial architect. Yeah, Lutyens and Herbert Baker, both of whom worked on New Delhi. Yeah. Reginald Blomfield, who redesigned Chequers. Yeah. Fabulous moustache.
他们邀请了基本上非常了不起的人参与其中。所以他们拥有英国顶尖的建筑师。勒琴斯（Lutyens），伟大的帝国建筑师。是的，勒琴斯和赫伯特·贝克（Herbert Baker），两人都曾参与新德里的设计。雷金纳德·布洛姆菲尔德（Reginald Blomfield），他重新设计了契克斯（Chequers）。是的。他留着极棒的胡子。
I mean, you can't have an imperial committee without a moustache. There's many moustaches on this committee. But also, we've already mentioned Kipling. But Kipling is the kind of literary advisor. He's the guy who comes up with the phrases. We could argue, I think reasonably, that Kipling is the author of Remembrance, that he created the Remembrance, many of the Remembrance rituals that we – and the sort of – I guess the language of Remembrance, isn't it? Because it's Kipling who comes up with the idea. So they have this brilliant idea.
我的意思是，没有胡子就组建不了一个帝国委员会。这个委员会有很多胡子。而且，我们之前已经提到过吉卜林。但吉卜林是某种文学顾问。他是那个想出那些悼词短句的人。我们可以相当合理地争辩说，吉卜林是“纪念”的缔造者，他创造了“纪念”活动，创造了许多我们今天所遵循的——以及某种——我想可以说是“纪念”的语言，对吧？因为正是吉卜林想出了这个主意。所以他们有了这个绝妙的想法：
Soldier of the Great War, known unto God. Known unto God. He does that. But also if you go to any major War wargraves cemetery have you been to some of the world war one um i have yeah cemeteries they're very moving aren't they they're oddly moving i i i've never had any desire to go and see them at all i always felt incredibly unsentimental about them um and then we went to eep because that's where my grand my grandfather didn't die there but he got wounded and invalided out so we went there there, see the Menem Gate and everything.
“伟大战争的士兵，神所知晓”（Soldier of the Great War, known unto God）。“神所知晓”。这是他想出来的。而且如果你去任何主要的战争公墓——你去过一些一战的……我去过，是的。公墓，它们非常感人，不是吗？它们有一种奇特触动人心的力量。我以前从来没有任何愿望去参观它们，我总是觉得自己对它们毫无感触……
And they are kind of overwhelming. Yeah. And you go there and they have this thing called, what's it called? The Stone of Remembrance, which is this kind of classic kind of Lutyens construction, an abstract, almost slightly modernist stone. And on that, you have Kipling's line that he took from Ecclesiasticus,
然后我们去了伊珀尔（Ypres），因为那是我的祖父——我的祖父虽然没有死在那里，但他受了伤，并被遣送回国了。所以我们去了那里，看到了门宁门（Menen Gate）和所有这些。它们确实有种压倒性的力量。是的。当你去到那里时，它们有一个东西叫什么来着？纪念之石（Stone of Remembrance），这是那种经典的勒琴斯式建筑，一块抽象的、几乎带有轻微现代主义风格的石头。在那上面，你刻着吉卜林从《传道书》（Ecclesiasticus）中摘录的诗句：
their names liveth forevermore. Can I pick up on that? Go on. In a way that will annoy you. Don't. Okay, I'm going to. So in the main cemeteries, there are two kind of commanding images.
“他们的名字将永远流传”（their names liveth forevermore）。我可以接着这个话题说吗？请便。用一种会惹恼你的方式。别这样。好吧，我偏要说。所以在主要公墓里，有两种核心的标志性意象。
So you have the Stone of Remembrance and you have a Cross of Sacrifice. So Reginald Blomfield designed the Cross of Sacrifice with his moustache. Oh, I know where you're going with this. Oh goodness sake so the stone of remembrance yes um is modeled on the the lineaments of the of the parthenon yeah and i think that that lurking behind a lot of this is uh ancient greece okay i didn't think you were going there so i'm delighted can i elaborate on that do do because they surprised me i thought it was all going to be about christianity we'll we'll be coming to that
所以你有纪念之石，还有一座牺牲十字架（Cross of Sacrifice）。雷金纳德·布洛姆菲尔德带着他的胡子设计了牺牲十字架……哦，我知道你要扯到哪里去了。哦天哪！所以纪念之石，是的……是以帕台农神庙（Parthenon）的线条为蓝本建造的，对吧？我认为潜藏在这一切背后的，其实是古希腊。好吧，我没想到你会扯到那儿去，所以我很高兴。我能详细阐述一下吗？请讲，请讲。因为它们让我感到意外，我原以为这全都是关于基督教的呢。我们待会儿会谈到那个的，
i can assure you oh no so a lot of this is an age where the um the kind of people who are organizing remembrance committees and all that kind of stuff are absolutely steeped in ancient Greece, Greek literature and so on. During the war, London buses have extracts from Pericles' funeral oration on the side. And this funeral oration is given by Pericles in the second year of the Peloponnesian War. And it's an annual ritual where somebody gives a talk to commemorate the dead. And preceding this, Thucydides says that what the Athenians do is that they gather up the bones, the bodies and the bones of those who've died in battle. They bring them back to Athens and they lay them in a kind of tent outside Athens. And they organize them up into the 10 tribes.
我向你们保证。哦，不！所以这一切都发生在一个……那些组织纪念委员会以及诸如此类事情的人绝对浸淫在古希腊、希腊文学等之中的时代。战争期间，伦敦的公交车车身上印着伯里克利（Pericles）《阵亡将士国葬演说》（funeral oration）的片段。这篇葬礼演说是伯里克利在伯罗奔尼撒战争（Peloponnesian War）第二年发表的。这是一个年度仪式，由某人发表讲话来纪念死者。在此之前，修昔底德（Thucydides）说，雅典人的做法是收集在战斗中牺牲之人的骨灰、遗体和骨骼。他们把遗体运回雅典，将之安放在雅典城外的一个帐篷里。并按十个部落将他们归类。
Every Athenian citizen belongs to one of 10 tribes. And then after three days, they all get put into 10 coffins and carried away and buried. But there is an 11th coffin. And this coffin, Thucydides says, is empty to commemorate those. They don't know who they are, who the bodies are. So there's a strong element there of kind of the idea that citizen soldiers who've died fighting for their country should be properly commemorated. There's a sense that you have to incorporate those who are missing, those who are unknown, those whose identities have been lost. And it's kind of woven into the idea that the Parthenon itself and the Periclean rebuilding
每个雅典公民都属于十个部落之一。三天后，遗体被放入十口棺材中抬走安葬。但还有第十一口棺材。修昔底德说，这口棺材是空的，用来纪念那些人——那些他们不知道是谁、不知道遗体是谁的人。所以这里面有一个强烈的元素，即那种为国捐躯的公民士兵应该得到妥善纪念的理念。其中有一种意识，即你必须将那些失踪的、未知的、身份已经湮没的人纳入其中。这与帕台农神庙本身以及伯里克利在公元前480年波斯人烧毁雅典卫城后对卫城的重建理念交织在一起——很长一段时间里，它都被空置着，作为一种战争纪念碑，后来伯里克利对其进行了重新开发。但同样地，你知道的，所有那些人们会……除了最著名的那些建筑之外，它最初就是作为纪念马拉松战役（Marathon）死难者和萨拉米斯（Salamis）伟大胜利的纪念碑而设计的。我确信这一定构成了一部分……如果收听节目的听众中有比我更了解这一点的人，我会非常感兴趣。但这一定……我认为它至少在潜意识里对人们的思维产生了影响。还有，汤姆，那座阵亡将士纪念碑（Cenotaph）。你在公墓里看到的纪念之石，在设计上与阵亡将士纪念碑有着异曲同工之妙，我并不是说它们完全一样。而阵亡将士纪念碑，这个词本身是什么意思？Kenetaphion。
of the Acropolis after the Persians had burnt it in 480 BC, for a long while it was left empty as a kind of war memorial, and then Pericles redevelops it. But again, it's, you know, all the kind of the famous buildings that people will kind of, apart from the most famous, it's designed as a memorial to the dead of Marathon and to the great victory at Salamis. And I'm sure that that must be a part of what is, you know, if there are people listening who know more about this than me, I'd be very interested. But it must, I think it must be kind of at the very least, even if it's subconsciously playing on the mind. But also the fact, the cenotaph, Tom. So the stone of remembrance that you get in the cemeteries is not dissimilar, I'm not totally dissimilar in design from the cenotaph. And the cenotaph, the very word of it, what is it? Kenetaphion.
是的，衣冠冢。一座空坟墓。所以，我的意思是，这个事实显然存在于……我的意思是，甚至都不是在潜意识里，它一定是有意识地存在着一种回溯古希腊的想法。确实如此。所以你确实有那种希腊元素，但随后当然，你会面临这样一个问题：你该如何处理基督教？是的。他们为那个十字架发生了激烈的争论，不是吗？争得非常厉害。有些人说我们根本不应该竖立十字架，这很有趣，因为如果是一百年前，他们是绝不会这么说的。完全正确。但事实上，英国在绝大多数程度上依然是一个基督教国家。而第一次世界大战在某种程度上极大地复兴了基督教，人们觉得基督教能够引导人们的悲痛，能够为人们为什么牺牲、死者去了哪里提供一种解释。
Yes, an empty tomb. An empty tomb. So, I mean, the fact that clearly is there in i mean not even in the subconscious it must be there consciously an idea of looking back to the greeks it is and so you have you do have that kind of greek element but then of course you have the question of what do you do about christianity yeah they have huge arguments about that cross don't they they're massive some people say we shouldn't have a cross at all, which is interesting because they wouldn't have said that 100 years earlier. Exactly. But actually, Britain remains overwhelmingly a Christian country. And the First World War had served to kind of massively revive Christianity as something that
因此，纪念活动中的基督教元素实际上也极其重要……我认为它聚焦于无名战士（unknown warrior）的形象。是的，也许我们应该在休息之后再谈这个，你觉得呢？嗯，在我们谈之前——无名战士是1920年的事，所以在我们谈到那之前，我们还有一点时间可以聊聊1919年发生的事情。好的，是的。所以1919年，你可能会认为第一次重大的纪念时刻是在一年后到来，但事实并非如此。它大约发生在六个月后，六、七个月后。他们在伦敦举行了一场盛大的游行，我想是在1919年6月还是7月？
people felt that channeled people's grief, that kind of gave an explanation for why people had died where the dead had gone and so the christian element of remembrance is actually incredibly important as well uh and i think is focused on the figure of the unknown warrior yes perhaps we should come to after a break do you think uh well let's just before let's do the unknown warriors kind of 1920 but so before we do, we've got a little bit of time where we can talk about what happened in 1919. Okay, yes. So 1919, you might think that the first sort of big moment of remembrance happens a year on, but it actually doesn't. It happens about six months later, six or seven months. So they have a huge parade in London in, I think, was it June, July 1919?
关于那场游行，有趣的是它提醒了你，其实并不全都是厄运、阴霾和悲痛。其中也有很多的庆祝活动。所以，虽然士兵们在战争结束时往往说他们是用沉默来标记这一刻的。他们不知道该想些什么。他们只感到内心空虚。但实际上在伦敦、巴黎等地，爆发了盛大的狂欢式的庆祝活动，他们举行了这场盛大的游行——正是在那个时候，阵亡将士纪念碑首次出现，当时它是用木头建造的。在伦敦，他们举行了由退伍军人等参加的盛大游行，然后
And what's interesting about that is it reminds you that actually it's not all doom and gloom and kind of grief. There's a lot of celebration as well. So in, although soldiers themselves, when the war ended, were often, they said they marked it with silence. They didn't know what to think. They just felt empty. But actually in London and Paris and so on on there's great orgies of kind of celebration and they have this big parade that's when the senator first appears when it's first built in wood um in london they have this huge parade of kind of veterans and so on and then
在1919年11月，他们举行了一场盛大的庆祝宴会，英王乔治五世和法兰西共和国总统都出席了。他们在报纸上为此受到了一些批评，人们说：“哦，我们应该举办这样的市场活动吗？是的，这是庆祝的方式吗？”因为他们非常显眼地没有做的一件事——我的意思是，比如说在巴黎——就是竖立类似凯旋门那样的东西。不，他们没有，他们没有。所以任何地方都没有凯旋主义（triumphalist）的建筑。不，这挺有意思的。他们引入的另一件事，我认为这与缺乏凯旋主义不谋而合，那就是两分钟默哀。所以这是全新的，以前从未有过。你知道这个习俗是从哪里来的吗？不知道。
they have a big blowout banquet in november 1919 king george v and the president of the french republic and they actually get a bit of criticism for that in the papers they say you know should we be having market yeah is this the way to market because what what they very notably don't do i mean you know say in paris is stick up something like the arc de triomphe no they don't they don't so there's no triumphalist architecture anywhere no that's quite interesting and the other thing that they they bring in as well which i think it chimes with what the lack of triumphalism is the two-minute silence so that is new that has never been done before do you know where that comes from no it comes from south africa interestingly so the guy who was the mayor of cape town had lost his son and um they used to fire at the
有趣的是，它源自南非。开普敦（Cape Town）的市长失去了他的儿子，呃，他们习惯于在开普敦信号山（Signal Hill）的正午时分鸣放正午礼炮，我猜这可能是某种留给过往船只之类的传统仪式。然后他们说：“嗯，我们为什么不进行两分钟的默哀呢？”实际上，他们最初是从三分钟默哀开始的。市长本人说：“时间太长了。大家都感到无聊，开始走动、坐立不安。所以我们还是进行两分钟的默哀吧。”路透社随后对此进行了报道。英国人开始效仿。
noonday gun at signal hill at cape town at noon, which I assume was a ritual left over from kind of passing ships or something. And they say, well, why don't we have a two minute silence? They start off with a three minute silence, actually. And the mayor himself says, it's too long. Everyone got bored and started shuffling around and fidgeting. So let's have a two minute silence. Reuters then reported it. People in Britain started to copy it.
乔治五世在11月11日11日前几天发表了一项公开声明，他在声明中说，这是一项伟大的创新。我们都应该这样做。结果所有人都照做了。11号这一天，一切都停了下来。两分钟的默哀得到了严格的尊重……
And George V publishes a sort of public declaration a few days before the 11th of November 1919 in which he says, there's this great innovation. We should all do it. And everybody does do it. And everything stops on the 11th. And the two minutes is rigorously sort of respected um and then ever
从那以后，你知道的，两分钟默哀的概念已经成为……有趣的是，南非这位失去儿子的父亲，就像失去儿子的吉卜林一样，你确实能感觉到，战争结束后涌现出来的仪式，是由那些激发这些仪式的、人们内心深处的个人悲痛所驱动的。正是这些仪式，与人们想要纪念那些牺牲者的更广泛的情感产生共鸣，你不觉得吗？这里面也许还有一种潜意识里的内疚感，那就是……是的，绝对有。一个把儿子送上战场并失去儿子的父亲，正如吉卜林一样。是的，我认为其中包含着巨大的内疚感。我认为……
since you know that's the idea of the two-minute silence has become well it's so it's interesting that that this guy in south africa lost a son as kipling lost a son and you do get the sense that the the rituals that emerge in the wake of the war are powered by a personal sense of grief from yeah the people who are inspiring this and it's it's the the rituals that kind of chime with a broader sense of people wanting to to market that that work don't you think it's it's it's there's an element maybe subconscious of guilt as well that yeah absolutely a father who sent his son with with Kipling yeah I think there's a huge element of that and I think um yeah it's also interesting that they're so sacred aren't they you were talking about this sort of when I was thinking about Athens the two
是的，同样有趣的是它们是如此神圣，不是吗？你之前谈到这一点……当我想到雅典时，两分钟默哀是神圣的，如果你打断它，人们会觉得……我的意思是，那是一种极其亵渎的行为，就像亵渎阵亡将士纪念碑一样，你不觉得吗？在某种程度上，这些是现代英国文化中最神圣的事物。嗯，我认为这真的很有趣。而且我认为这是我们可以探讨的话题，因为我认为在某种程度上，尽管它的大部分根基在于基督教仪式，但它已经取代了基督教仪式。它确实为通常情况下……
minute silence is sacred you interrupt it and people think I mean that's an incredibly profane thing to do like desecrating the cenotaph don't you think I, those are the most sacred things in modern British culture, to some extent. Well, I think that is really interesting. And I think it's something that we could talk about, because I think in a way, although it's kind of rooted a lot of it in Christian ritual, it has come to replace Christian ritual. And it does kind of provide, I suppose, a vent for sentiments and feelings that in general we you know contemporary british society doesn't provide a vent for which is why i think it is it's both so important and also kind of on the margin so contested so i think i think we should
我们——你知道的，当代英国社会所无法提供发泄渠道的情感和情绪——提供了一个宣泄口，这就是为什么我认为它既如此重要，同时又处于边缘地位，充满争议。所以我想我们应该……在这里休息一下，当我们回来时，我们将探讨那位阵亡战士，这是一个惊人的故事，然后看看它的遗产如何延续到今天。还有虞美人花。我们还没谈到虞美人花呢。我们一定会谈到虞美人花的。好吧。休息之后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
we should take a break here and when we come back we should look at the um the fallen warrior which is an amazing story um and then look at how that kind of, the legacy of that into the present day. And poppies. We haven't talked about poppies. We'll definitely talk about poppies. All right. See you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《历史的 rest》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论，以及各种娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告的收听体验、加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票的资格，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
所以，汤姆，这个星期日，本季的重头活动：下午5点，伦敦莱斯特广场（Leicester Square）的奥顿电影院（Odeon），《历史的 rest》现场秀。现在只剩下几天时间了。你感到兴奋吗？你紧张吗？伦敦西区的璀璨中心。这将是一场多么璀璨的盛会啊！你和我将探讨历史与电影之间的关系。等不及了。你还没说你是兴奋还是紧张。当然，我又兴奋又紧张。是的，我们两个都是。在充满……等不及了。你还没说你是兴奋还是紧张。当然了，我既兴奋又紧张。
So Tom, this Sunday, the event of the season, 5pm, Leicester Square in London, the Odeon, the rest is history live. There are only a few days left now. Are you excited? Are you nervous? The glittering heart of London's West End. What a glittering occasion it will be. You and me looking at the relationship between history and cinema. Can't wait for it. You haven't said if you're excited or you're nervous. Of course, I'm excited and nervous. Yeah, we're both. While simultaneously't wait for it. You haven't said if you're excited or you're nervous. Of course. Well, I'm excited and nervous.
是的，我们俩都是。与此同时又充满信心。这可真不少。但以一种非常谦逊的方式，我想。我知道这将是一场精彩的演出，因为我们已经讨论过了，也把所有内容都敲定了。这一定会非常棒。而且剩下的门票已经不多了。
Yeah, we're both. While simultaneously being full of confidence. That's a lot. But in a very modest way, I think. I know it's going to be a great show because we've talked it out and we've worked it all out. It's going to be fabulous. And there are very few tickets left.
非常、非常少。我可不是在瞎说。上次剩下的就不多，但现在真的是非常非常少。是的，甚至更少。所以……抓紧时间，趁还没卖完赶紧买吧。你可以在Ticketmaster上搜索“podicon”（p-o-d-i-c-o-n）来找到它，或者直接搜索“rest is history live”。正如多米尼克所说，我既兴奋紧张又充满信心，我兼具了所有这些感受。到时候见。我们到时见。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。
Very, very few. I'm not just saying that. Last time there were very few, but now there are really very very few yeah even fewer so um hurry hurry while stocks last and you can find it by looking for podicon on ticketmaster p-o-d-i-c-o-n or just search for rest is history live and as don't we said i'm both excited nervous and full of confidence i'm all of those things too. See you then. We'll see you there. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
我们正在谈论纪念活动，尤其是对第一次世界大战结束的纪念，这已经成为所有纪念仪式的模板。所以，汤姆，你说你想谈谈无名战士，我知道你对这个话题了解很多。这是一个很棒的故事。你怎么可能对它不了解呢？所以我其实对此一无所知……
We're talking about remembrance, and in particular, remembering the end of the First World War, which has become the template for all rituals of remembrance. So Tom, you said you wanted to talk about The Unknown Warrior, which I know you know a lot about. And it is a great story. Why wouldn't you know a lot about it? So I didn't really know anything about it
直到昨天。然后我经历了一次绝对糟糕透顶的旅程，从索尔兹伯里（Salisbury）返回，那里当然发生了一起火车事故。我必须赶回伦敦。所以有很多铁路替代公交服务。于是我发现了一个极棒的……呃，播客，我想它是去年夏天播出的，叫做……呃……《无名战士》，大约20分钟长。如果你感兴趣的话，我强烈推荐它。所以我要讲的一切都源于那个播客，在此致歉。我真不敢相信你在节目里为竞争对手的播客做广告。好吧，你知道的……如果不听他们做的每一期节目，我对这个主题可以说是知之甚少。这是一个惊人的故事。是的。它的构想似乎最早可以追溯到修昔底德。我听说，在你的最爱——石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因战争（Schleswig-Holstein war）中，似乎也做过类似的事情。我不知道这一点。是的，据说是这样的。
until yesterday. And then I had an absolutely horrendous journey back from Salisbury, where of course there'd been this train accident. I had to get back to London. So there were a lot of rail replacement bus services. So I found a fantastic uh podcast which i think went out last summer called the the um the unknown warrior uh little
但主要幕后推手是一个非凡的人，我以前从未听说过他，但他简直是个英雄。大卫·雷尔顿牧师（The Reverend David Railton）。是的，他非常令人印象深刻。一个非常令人印象深刻的人。
20 minute ones i highly recommend it if you are interested so everything i'm going to say now derives from that so apologies i can't believe you're advertising rival podcasts on that well you know i i literally would know nothing about the subject unless I'd listened to every single episode they did. It's an amazing story. Yeah. And the idea for it seems to have originated perhaps with Thucydides. Perhaps I gather that something similar to this was done in your favourite war, the Schleswig-Holstein war. I didn't know that. Yeah, apparently.
20分钟的那期我非常推荐，如果你感兴趣的话。我接下来要说的一切都源于那一期，所以抱歉。真不敢相信你竟然在节目里宣传竞争对手的播客。好吧，你知道的，如果不是听了他们做过的每一集节目，我对这个主题可以说一无所知。这是一个了不起的故事。是的。而且这个想法似乎最早可以追溯到修昔底德。也许吧，我听说类似的事情也发生在你们最喜欢的战争——石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因战争中。我不知道这一点。是的，显然是这样的。
But the guy who's chiefly behind it is this remarkable man who I'd never heard of, but who is just what a hero. The Reverend David Railton. Yeah, he's very impressive. A very impressive man.
但主要推动这件事的人是一个了不起的人，我以前从未听说过他，但他简直是个英雄。雷维伦德·大卫·雷尔顿。是的，他非常令人印象深刻。一个非常令人印象深刻的人。
Vicar, signs up, becomes a kind of vicar in the army. Wins the MC, never talks about it. His son then got the MC in the Second World War, never talked about it. And his grandson suddenly discovered that his dad and his grandfather had both won the MC and never talked about it. That's a lot of pressure on the grandson. It's a kind of example of modesty that both of us i think yeah would find hard to compute um and he had uh so obviously had a very heroic war record um he was involved in um clearing a a wood of corpses so he'd kind of had to go in and and pick up bits of flesh and body. I mean, just horrible.
牧师，报名参军，成为了军队里的一种牧师。荣获军功十字勋章（MC），却从不提起。他的儿子后来在二战中也获得了军功十字勋章，也从不提起。而他的孙子突然发现，自己的父亲和祖父竟然都获得过军功十字勋章，却从来没提过。这给孙子带来了巨大的压力。我觉得我们俩都会觉得这种谦逊的榜样很难理解，嗯，而且他——显然有着非常英勇的战争记录——他曾参与清理一处堆满尸体的树林，所以他不得不走进去，捡起一块块的血肉和尸体。我的意思是，简直太可怕了。
And the story that he told late in his life was that he'd seen a rough white cross with the words to an unknown British soldier on it. That's right. So Armentier, that's the place. Yeah. Apparently, this may be a slightly false memory. Oh, that's a bit disappointing. Well, you built him up and then you tear him down. No, no, I'm not saying that he lied.
他晚年讲述的故事是，他看到过一个粗糙的白色十字架，上面写着“致一位不知名的英国士兵”。没错。阿尔芒蒂耶，就是那个地方。是的。显然，这可能是一个稍微有点错误的记忆。哦，那就有点让人失望了。好吧，你先把他捧得很高，然后再把他踩下去。不，不，我不是说他在撒谎。
It's a bit of British media. No, I think that, you know, the memory plays tricks and you can, whatever. I mean, we don't know. But there was an earlier account in which he didn't mention this. But anyway, so he dwells on this idea that there should be, you know, a body of an unknown soldier should be brought back to London and should be placed in Westminster Abbey. And he sits on this and dwells on this. And I hadn't realised that it's only in the summer
这有点像英国媒体的作风。不，我觉得，你知道，记忆会捉弄人，而且你可以，随便吧。我的意思是，我们不知道。但之前曾有过另一种说法，其中他并未提及此事。不过不管怎样，他纠结于这样一个想法：应该有一个，你知道，一个无名士兵的遗体应该被带回伦敦，并安放在威斯敏斯特教堂。他对此念念不忘，反复思量。我之前没意识到，直到1920年夏天
of 1920 that he writes to the Dean of Westminster with this proposal. Dean of Westminster goes, that's a brilliant idea. Lloyd George goes, that's a brilliant idea. George V goes, not sure about that. Yeah, that's extraordinary, isn't it the george fifth is so skeptical about it i think it's just because he's so unimaginative yeah and he you know he's he's only interested in stamp collecting and creasing his trousers on the wrong side so he doesn't have any you know he can't conceive of how this would be a very romantic and moving gesture and so essentially it's it all has to be organized within a few weeks but they do it, it's an amazing story and they organise it amazingly and this is where basically the whole superstructure of Remembrance
他才就这个提议写信给威斯敏斯特教堂的院长。威斯敏斯特教堂的院长说，这主意绝了。劳埃德·乔治说，这主意绝了。乔治五世则说，这事我不太确定。是的，这太不可思议了，不是吗？乔治五世竟然对此如此怀疑。我想这只是因为他太缺乏想象力了。是的，而且他，你知道的，他只对集邮和把裤线熨错边感兴趣，所以他根本没有，你知道的，他无法想象这会是一个多么浪漫和感人的姿态。因此，从本质上讲，这一切都必须在短短几周内组织完成，但他们做到了，这是一个惊人的故事，他们惊人地完成了这一切。这就是为什么基本上整个阵亡将士纪念的超级结构
comes to be worked out within a few weeks so they get four bodies don't they, one from Eep one from Arras, one from the Battle of the Aene and one from the Somme and they cover the meat, they're all in sort of quite plain coffins and they're covered with the Union Jack and then they get a Brigadier General to come in and he closes his eyes and they cover the meat. They're all in sort of quite plain coffins and they're covered with the Union Jack.
在短短几周内就被构建了出来。所以他们找到了四具遗体，对吧？一具来自伊普尔，一具来自阿拉斯，一具来自埃纳河战役，还有一具来自索姆河。他们用——它们都装在相当简陋的棺材里，上面盖着英国国旗，然后他们请来了一位准将，他闭上眼睛，然后盖上肉。它们都装在相当简陋的棺材里，上面盖着英国国旗。
And then they get a Brigadier General to come in and he closes his eyes and puts his hand on one of the coffins. Brigadier General Wyatt. Yeah. Who's in command of British troops in France. That's right. And he puts his hand on one of them and then the others are taken away. The other three get taken away.
然后他们请来了一位准将，他闭上眼睛，把手放在其中一口棺材上。怀亚特准将。是的。当时指挥驻法英国军队的那位。没错。他把手放在其中一口棺材上，然后其他的就被抬走了。另外三具被抬走了。
Yeah. And then it's like a game show. It is, yes. The winner proceeds to the next round where he's put into a new coffin. Well, no, the winner's won. Yeah. You know, there is no further round. He's hit the bullseye.
是的。然后这就跟游戏节目一样。确实是，是的。获胜者进入下一轮，被装进一口新棺材里。好吧，不，获胜者已经赢了。是的。你知道的，没有下一轮了。他正中靶心。
Fair enough. He's put in a new coffin made of the, I didn't think we'd be. It's a coffin. It's a coffin. The coffin is made of wood from Hampton Court. Hampton Court Palace of Oak. Yeah, of which Oak. Hampton Court Palace. And a Yeah, Hampton Court Palace.
也对。他被装进了一口新棺材里，这棺材是用——我没想到我们会——这是一口棺材。这是一口棺材。这口棺材是用汉普顿宫的木头做的。汉普顿宫的橡木。是的，什么橡木。汉普顿宫。还有一把——汉普顿宫。
And a sword, a crusader's sword from the Tower of London. I know, very good. Put on the top and he's buried in the earth of France. And, you know, we're slightly kind of background of Anglo-French hostility at the moment over fish. But this story is a reminder of how close and intimate the bonds between France and Britain were. That this unknown warrior, British soldier, is buried in French soil, gets escorted by a French escort to Boulogne. Marshal Foch, who was in command of the Allied forces in 1918, salutes it. And it gets taken on to HMS Verdun, which has been named after the Great Battle.
还有一把剑，一把来自伦敦塔的十字军之剑。我知道，非常好。放在棺材顶部，然后他被埋葬在法国的土地上。而且，你知道的，我们目前稍微有点英法因捕鱼问题而产生敌意的背景。但这个故事提醒我们，法国和英国之间的纽带曾经是多么紧密和亲密。这位不知名的战士，这位英国士兵，被埋葬在法国的土地上，由法国护送队护送到滨海布洛涅。1918年盟军最高指挥官福煦元帅向他敬礼。随后他被运上了“凡尔登号”驱逐舰（HMS Verdun），这艘船是以那场伟大战役命名的。
The whole children of the town are there. Everybody. Everybody. The entire town is there to see it. I mean, an incredibly moving moment. As you say, HMS Verdun. I mean, it couldn't be more aptly named. The battle is the Somme to the French, their equivalent of this huge sacrifice.
全镇的孩子们都在那里。所有人都来了。整个城镇的人都在那里目送它。我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的感人的时刻。正如你所说，“凡尔登号”驱逐舰。我的意思是，再没有比这更贴切的名字了。对法国人来说，这场战役就是索姆河战役，相当于他们那种巨大的牺牲。
And then it ends up even the even the the when it gets to london the internment in westminster abbey is incredibly moving the whole the whole thing i mean the i think the only thing that you compare it to is diana's funeral oh my god but the no but in terms of in terms of of kind of unexpected impact of a funeral yeah so there are you know people who live through it will remember the vast numbers of crowds that came out for Diana's funeral, but the crowds for this were much, much larger. And they were gathering at Dover as HMS Verdun landed.
然后它甚至——甚至当它到达伦敦时，在威斯敏斯特教堂的安葬仪式也极其感人。整场活动——我的意思是，我觉得唯一能与之相比的只有戴安娜的王妃的葬礼了。天哪！但是，不，但是就……就葬礼带来的某种意料之外的影响力而言，是的，经历过那个时代的人会记得为戴安娜葬礼走上街头的庞大人群，但为这个仪式聚集的人群要庞大得多、多得多。当“凡尔登号”在多佛靠岸时，人群就已经在那里聚集了。
It lined the rail route from Dover to Victoria. At Victoria, there's a guard comes and stands vigil over it overnight. And apparently every year still to this day between platform 8 and 9 a vigil is held. Is that right? Apparently so, yes. That's a lovely detail, I didn't know that.
人群排满了从多佛到维多利亚车站的铁路线。在维多利亚车站，有一队卫兵通宵守夜。据说直到今天，每年的8号和9号站台之间仍然会举行守夜活动。是这样吗？据说是的，没错。这是一个很棒的细节，我之前不知道。
And then it gets taken and corteged through down the Mall, down Whitehall, past the Cenotaph and this is when Lutch in Cenotaph is unveiled. Yeah. And it gets taken into Westminster Abbey. And the whole thing has been organised by Lord Curzon. A very superior person.
然后它被护送着穿过林荫大道（the Mall），经过白厅（Whitehall），走过和平纪念碑（Cenotaph）——也就是在这个时候，伦敦的和平纪念碑揭幕了。是的。随后它被迎入威斯敏斯特教堂。整个活动都是由寇松勋爵（Lord Curzon）组织操办的。一个非常高傲的人。
A very superior person. But who in this case plays a blinder because he's the Foreign Secretary. He's the former Viceroy of India. He's kind of a tremendously stiff person, but has an absolutely brilliant idea for ritual and all that kind of stuff. And he makes sure that it's escorted in past an escort of everyone who's won the VC. And he's made sure that it's not just kind of the great and the good. It's not just kind of people from high society who are at Westminster Abbey.
一个非常高傲的人。但在这种情况下，他表现得极其出色，因为他是外交大臣。他是前印度总督。他是一个非常死板的人，但对于仪式和诸如此类的事情却有着绝对绝妙的点子。他确保在遗体被护送入内时，两侧站满了所有获得过维多利亚十字勋章（VC）的人作为仪仗队。并且他确保这不仅仅是那些显赫和大人物。不仅是威斯敏斯特教堂里那些上流社会的人。
But he specifies that it should be women who've lost their husbands and their sons. Yeah, I think that's such a lovely incredibly moving detail isn't it very very moving and and then it's visited isn't it after the ceremony it is visited by millions of people go to pay their respects yeah um and you can sort of understand it actually because it's the perfect symbol for a kind of democratic war. Because it could be anyone. Yeah, exactly. Absolutely. So that's 1920.
他还特意指明，应该让那些失去了丈夫和儿子的女性们也参与进来。是的，我觉得这是一个非常可爱、极其感人的细节，不是吗？非常非常感人。然后——仪式结束后，无数人会前去瞻仰，对吗？无数人前去表达敬意，是的。嗯，其实你完全可以理解，因为这是一种完美象征，代表了一种民主性质的战争。因为死者可能是任何人。是的，完全如此。绝对的。所以那是1920年。
But also, Dominic, on the topic of royalty and the unknown warrior, I gather that when Elizabeth Bowes Lyon married the future George VI, she laid her bouquet on the tomb of the unknown warrior to commemorate her brother who died at the Battle of Loos but also isn't that a brilliant a brilliantly loaded PR gesture because that's
不过，多米尼克，说到皇室与无名战士的话题，我了解到，伊丽莎白·鲍斯-莱恩（Elizabeth Bowes Lyon）嫁给未来的国王乔治六世时，她把自己的新娘捧花放在了无名战士的墓碑上，以此纪念她在洛斯战役（Battle of Loos）中牺牲的哥哥。但难道这也是一个绝妙的、极具政治寓意的公关手腕吗？因为那是
you know she and her husband were going to be all about self-sacrifice and duty and responsibility in contrast to his older brother, who's just narcissistic shit. Yes. Yes. Even though he's the president of the Imperial War Graves Commission. Yes.
你知道的，她和她的丈夫将代表自我牺牲、责任与担当，与他那个仅仅是个自恋废物的哥哥形成鲜明对比。是的。是的。尽管他还是帝国战争墓地委员会的主席。是的。
But apparently this is now what royal brides always do. Yeah, they do. Didn't Kate Middleton do this on her wedding day? Yes, I think so. Yes, I think so. So that's 1920 that happens. And then 1921 is when you have the creation of the british legion and this is douglas haig who most people if they
但显然，现在这成了皇家新娘们的惯例。是的，确实如此。凯特·米德尔顿在她的婚礼日不也这么做了吗？是的，我想是的。是的，我想是的。所以1920年发生了这件事。然后到了1921年，英国荣军联合会（British Legion）成立了。这是道格拉斯·黑格（Douglas Haig）发起的，大多数人如果
haven't been persuaded by gary sheffield's last appearance on the podcast they will think of douglas haig as the butcher of the psalm and all this kind of thing but douglas haig actually is incredibly um has has his he's beloved of lots of servicemen because of all his efforts after the war to kind of raise money for injured servicemen and so on in the British Legion. And I think he was a pallbearer for the unknown warrior. Yes, I think he was. Exactly. So I think there are six million men who served in the war. And this is a time of enormous unemployment in the early 1920s.
没有被加里·谢菲尔德（Gary Sheffield）上一次在播客中的发言说服的话，他们大概会把道格拉斯·黑格视为“索姆河的屠夫”诸如此类。但实际上，道格拉斯·黑格非常……他在退伍军人中备受爱戴，因为战后他为受伤退伍军人筹集资金等做出了巨大努力，并通过英国荣军联合会帮助了他们。而且我认为他还是无名战士的抬棺人之一。是的，我想他是的。没错。所以我想当时有六百万男儿参军作战。那是20世纪20年代早期，一个失业率极高的时期。
So they haven't come back to a kind of home's fit for heroes as they were promised and and david david railton that the guy who comes up with the idea for the unknown warrior i mean he he goes back and he commits himself to looking to caring for the absolute poorest among the that you know veterans who've come back you've absolutely lost everything so you you built them up you're torn down then you built it back up again tom that's what this podcast is all about. Yeah. It's an emotional rollercoaster. So the British Legion is what gives rise to, obviously,
所以他们并没有像承诺的那样回到“适合英雄居住的家园”。而且大卫·雷尔顿（David Railton），那个提出无名战士创意的人，我的意思是，他回去后致力于照顾那些处境最艰难的人——那些返回家园、一无所有的退伍军人。所以，你先是把他们捧高，然后把他们踩下去，接着又把他们扶起来，汤姆，这就是这个播客的全部意义。是的。这就像坐过山车一样情绪起伏。所以，英国荣军联合会孕育出了，显而易见，
the best-known symbol of remembrance, which lots of people will be wearing maybe even as they listen to this podcast, which is the poppy, which Tom Holland says he doesn't wear. So I'm not trying to get you cancelled, Tom, honestly. No, not at all. I can see the Daily Mail feature now. And who would write that? I can't imagine. They'd probably have to write it under...
那个最著名的纪念标志。很多人在听这个播客时可能身上就佩戴着它，那就是虞美人花（Poppy）。汤姆·霍兰说他自己不戴这东西。所以我可不是在试图让你被“取消资格”哦，汤姆，说真的。不，一点也不。我都能想象出《每日邮报》的专题报道了。谁会写那种文章呢？我简直无法想象。他们大概得署名……
They'd probably have to write it under... If it's written by A.N.Other, you know, you'll know who it is. Anon. An anonymous top historian speaks out. Anyway, right, so the poppy. You're laughing about poppies. No, I'm not. You also are cruising towards the end. No, so the poppy. You're laughing about poppies. No, I'm not. You also are cruising towards the end.
他们大概得署名……如果作者署名是“某某”（A.N.Other），你知道的，你就知道那是谁了。匿名。某匿名顶尖历史学家发声。总之，好吧，关于虞美人花。你居然在笑话虞美人花。不，我没有。你这家伙还在不知不觉中把话题扯远了。不，关于虞美人花。你居然在笑话虞美人花。不，我没有。你这家伙还在不知不觉中把话题扯远了。
No, I'm absolutely not. So the poppy comes from a poem, a lovely poem by a guy called John McRae, another very admirable chap. So he was a doctor. He's a Canadian. He's a lieutenant colonel. He loses a very close friend at the Second Battle of Ypres in the spring of 1915, which is the first
不，我绝对没有。所以，虞美人花源于一首诗，一首由约翰·麦克雷（John McRae）这位非常令人钦佩的仁兄所写的可爱诗作。他是一名医生。是个加拿大人。是个中校。他在1915年春天的第二次伊普尔战役中失去了一位非常亲密的朋友。那是
battle which the Germans used gas and he writes this famous poem that basically I think pretty much everybody in Britain now does in schools in Flanders Fields in Flanders Fields the poppies blow between the crosses row on row etc etc and this poem inspires it's a really interesting story because it inspires two people kind of simultaneously so one of them is an American academic who's a professor at the university of georgia this is a bit of a halloween story actually about importing a american tradition and she was called moina michael and she had what she worked with disabled american servicemen um and i think new york and she basically comes up with the idea of the poppy she thinks you know she decides to go she goes to get herself a poppy and she says i'll wear it every day to remember those who have fallen
德国人首次使用毒气的战役。他写下了这首著名的诗，基本上，我想现在英国学校里的每个人都会背吧：“在法兰德斯战场（In Flanders Fields），虞美人花迎风盛开，错落有致地生长在十字墓碑之间……”诸如此类。这首诗的诞生是一个非常有趣的故事，因为它同时启发了两个人。其中一个是美国学者，佐治亚大学的一位教授。这其实有点像个万圣节故事，关于引入美国的传统。她叫莫伊娜·迈克尔（Moina Michael），她曾与残疾的美国退伍军人共事，我想是在纽约。她基本上想出了虞美人花的点子。她想（她决定）去找一朵虞美人花，并说：“我要每天佩戴它，以缅怀那些牺牲的人。”
and she comes up with this idea about you know you could sell them and raise money for veterans and at the same time by a complete coincidence there's a french woman called anna guerra who had been born in france she was in britain the war broke out, but then she moved to the United States and was fundraising for disabled servicemen. And she comes up with the idea at the same time. And she comes back to Britain and she goes and has a meeting with the British Legion. And she says, I've got this great idea for a poppy.
她想出了一个点子，认为可以通过出售这些花来为退伍军人筹集资金。与此同时，完全出于巧合，有一位名叫安娜·盖兰（Anna Guérin）的法国女性，她出生于法国，战争爆发时人在英国，后来她搬到了美国，为残疾退伍军人筹款。她也在同一时间想出了这个点子。她回到英国，与英国荣军联合会进行了会面。她说：“我有一个关于虞美人花的绝妙主意。”
You know, the red Flanders fields, the poppies grew there. Everybody knows about it. And she says, I will pay to manufacture a million poppies in France. And Earl Hague says, that's a great idea. And the Legion said, well, we'll make another 8 million here in Britain. So they sell 9 million in the first year. Tells you what a massive hit it was.
“你知道的，法兰德斯战场的红色虞美人生长在那里。人尽皆知。”她说：“我愿意出资在法国制造一百万朵虞美人花。”黑格伯爵（Earl Haig）说：“这主意太棒了。”荣军联合会则说：“那好，我们将在英国本土再制造八百万朵。”所以在第一年他们就卖出了九百万朵。可见这是一个多么巨大的成功。
And they were originally just made of kind of fabric. They're very simple. But they say on them, on one side it says British Legion Remembrance Day, and on the other it says made by the women and children in the devastated areas of France. So there's your Anglo-French amity again, Tom. And it raises shed loads of money, tons of money, and becomes this huge phenomenon that people wear.
它们最初只是用某种织物制作的。非常简单。但在它们上面印着字：一面写着“英国荣军联合会纪念日”，另一面写着“由法国饱受战争蹂躏地区的妇女和儿童制造”。所以，英法友谊又双叒体现出来了，汤姆。这筹集了海量的资金，数不清的钱，并成为了一个人们纷纷佩戴的巨大文化现象。
They buy the poppies and they and they wear them every year so they build a factory in um aylesford i don't actually know where aylesford is but i'm just reading that out and they build another factory haig's wife opens a factory in scotland which i think still makes poppies in scotland to this day so you know it's a nice story but then of course you have the white poppy which some people just now that this is where the controversy kind of comes in, because even then in the 1920s and early 1930s, some people say, I don't want to wear the poppy because I think it glorifies war. And so sort of people who are in Britain. Yeah, it's people. It's the Cooperative Women's Guild. So it's early 30s, left-leaning, kind of well-meaning,
他们在艾尔斯福德（Aylesford）建立了一家工厂——其实我根本不知道艾尔斯福德在哪儿，我只是照着念出来的。他们还建了另一家工厂，黑格的妻子在苏格兰开办了一家工厂，我想直到今天苏格兰还在生产虞美人花。所以，这是一个美好的故事。但紧接着，当然，就有了白色的虞美人花（White Poppy）。有些人——看，争议就是从这里开始的。因为甚至早在20世纪20年代和30年代初，就有人说：“我不想佩戴虞美人花，因为我认为它美化了战争。”这主要是英国的一些人。是的，是一些人。是合作社妇女协会（Cooperative Women's Guild）。所以这是30年代早期，一些倾向左翼的、好意的、
kind of sort of what the playwright Michael Frank calls the kind of herbivorous tendency in Britain, kind of what we would now think of as slightly sort of Guardian reading-ish. And it's linked at this point to pacifism. So the 1930s is this huge at this point to pacifism. So the 1930s is this huge upsurge in pacifism, the Peace Pledge Union,
某种程度上被剧作家迈克尔·弗兰恩（Michael Frayn）称为英国“草食性倾向”群体的人。也就是我们现在认为的、有点偏向《卫报》读者那种调性的人。在当时，这与和平主义联系在一起。所以20世纪30年代，和平主义空前高涨，出现了和平誓言联盟（Peace Pledge Union），
and it's all about, so this is, this is never again. So this is different from the 20s because I don't think people were really all about never again
核心诉求就是“绝不再发生”（never again）。所以这与20年代不同，因为我认为在20年代，人们并没有那么强烈地
so much in the 20s. In the 20s, it was more, slightly more a muted, hurrah, we won. It was very sad, but we won and we're very pleased
把“绝不再发生”挂在嘴边。在20年代，那更像是一种稍微克制的、“乌拉，我们赢了”的心态。虽然很悲伤，但我们赢了，而且我们很高兴。
but in the 1930s that has morphed into a kind of never again war is hell war is hell and i think partly obviously because the specter of war is now approaching so people are more sort of jittery about war yes i i and i think that what's interesting about all the um tomb of the warrior the poppies the the graves and everything and the remembrance is that it it it constructs a kind of you know saying earlier a kind of post-christian way of marking well really are you remember our podcast with ronald hutton and he's talking about how um this time of year has always been commemorated as as a to, you know, you're leaving the summer, you're going into the winter, that this gets Christianized as a celebration to commemorate the dead. The Reformation gets rid of that.
但在30年代，这种心态已经演变成了一种“战争即地狱，绝不再有战争”的呐喊。我想部分原因显然是因为战争的阴影当时正在逼近，所以人们对战争更加神经质了。是的，我——而且我觉得，关于无名烈士墓、虞美人花、各种墓地以及纪念活动，所有这些最有趣的地方在于，它构建了一种——就像刚才说的——一种后基督教时代的悼念方式。你还记得我们跟罗纳德·赫顿（Ronald Hutton）的那期播客吗？他谈到这一年的这个时候是如何一直被作为纪念仪式的——你要告别夏天，迈入冬天，而这种节气演变成了纪念死者的基督教节日。宗教改革抹去了这一点。
In the 20th century, that kind of process of dechristianization, people forget Christian rituals. And yet what you see is, I i guess because of the coincidence of the fact that remembrance day is happening when it does that actually with halloween with guy forks with remembrance day you have this kind of effectively you know 12 day festival of the dead and remembrance day is the most important of those i think in, in terms of remembering. Well, it's the only one that's sacred, isn't it? Yeah, because it properly channels ideas of the sacred. But I think that the fact that it's kind of complemented by Halloween, people are nervous of the sacred, and people are afraid of where the sacred might lead.
但在20世纪，随着去基督教化进程的发展，人们逐渐淡忘了基督教的仪式。然而你所看到的是——我想由于巧合，阵亡将士纪念日恰好在这个特定的时间发生——实际上，伴随着万圣节、盖伊·福克斯之夜（Guy Fawkes Night）和阵亡将士纪念日，你实际上拥有了一个为期12天的“亡灵与纪念”节庆，而阵亡将士纪念日是其中最重要的一个，我认为就纪念意义而言是这样的。嗯，这是唯一神圣的日子，不是吗？是的，因为它恰如其分地引导了人们对神圣事物的概念。但我认为，它与万圣节相辅相成这一事实表明，人们对神圣既感到紧张，又对神圣可能导致的后果心存敬畏。
And I guess that the kind of nervousness about Remembrance Day in the 30s is a kind of expression of a reticence about Remembrance Day that endures into the present. Yeah. Although it's an argument, isn't it, that Remembrance Day has become, it's not just the sacred, it's become sentimentalized now in a way that it wasn't maybe in the 1920s and 30s. And it's been sentimentalized.
我猜，30年代对阵亡将士纪念日的这种紧张情绪，正是一种对纪念日保持沉默和保留的表达，这种情绪一直延续到了今天。是的。尽管也有人争辩说，阵亡将士纪念日已经变得——不仅仅是神圣，它现在已经被赋予了某种感伤色彩，而这在20世纪20年代和30年代时或许并不那么明显。它被感伤化了。
Well, so we all talk about the Second World War as well, because that, of course, so the Second World War then adds fuel to the requirement for remembrance and changes the date interestingly so they no longer want to have it on the 11th because it will interrupt war production if that's a weekday so they say we'll do it only on sundays and then after the war they move permanently i think the bishop the archbishop of westminster actually suggests to the atlee government that they're thinking, what should we do for both world wars? And he says, why don't we have it on Sunday? So that's why you have this slightly confusing thing in Britain,
嗯，所以我们也会谈论第二次世界大战，因为当然，二战为阵亡纪念的需求火上浇油，而且有趣的是它改变了纪念日期。所以人们不再希望把它定在11月11日，因为如果那是工作日的话，会打断军工生产。于是他们说：我们只在星期天举行纪念。战后来被永久固定下来——我想威斯敏斯特大主教实际上向艾德礼政府建议说他们在考虑：我们应该如何为两次世界大战举行纪念呢？他建议说：为什么不把它定在星期天呢？所以这就是为什么英国会出现这种稍微让人困惑的情况——
which I have to admit, until I looked into this, I always found a bit bewildering, that you basically have two remembrance days, one on the 11th, when sometimes you have the two-minute silence and things stop, particularly when you have the centenary of the first world war. And then you have the church services. And then you have the church services on the Sunday. But it's the Sunday that's the kind of designated day now isn't it and that's
我必须承认，在深入了解之前，我一直觉得有点莫名其妙：基本上你们有两个阵亡将士纪念日，一个是11日，有时会有两分钟默哀，一切都会停下来，特别是在第一次世界大战百年纪念的时候。然后你们还有教堂礼拜。接着在星期天还有一次教堂礼拜。但现在星期天才是那个指定的法定纪念日，对吧？而且那是
for both world wars but you see again i think that that that reflects this the way in which the ritual has kind of emerged from christian ceremony and it's kind of contested is there's always you know so that that kind of you know is it a greek is it a christian way of commemorating the dead it's always been there yeah but also it's it a Greek, is it a Christian way of commemorating the dead? It's always been there. Yeah. But also it's become... So we had a lot of questions. For example, Josh Glancy, who writes for the Sunday Times, says, is there a time when it'll cease to be dominated by the First World War? And lots of people have asked that about the World Wars and Remembrance. Already, the World Wars, I think, I mean, there has been a sense of the World Wars seeding some of their control of Remembrance't there i mean when you read um official kind
为了两次世界大战。但你看，再次说明，我认为这反映了这种仪式从基督教仪式中脱胎而来的过程，并且它一直饱受争议。总会有人（你知道的）提出质疑：这究竟是一种希腊式的还是基督教式的悼念死者的方式？这种争论一直都在。是的。但它也变成了……所以我们收到了很多问题。例如，为《星期日泰晤士报》撰稿的乔什·格兰西（Josh Glancy）就问：有没有那么一天，它不再由第一次世界大战主导？很多人都曾就世界大战和纪念活动提出过这个问题。事实上，世界大战的地位已经发生了一些变化，我觉得——英国荣军联合会的官方网站和其他地方在提到世界大战时，已经不像50年前那样占据压倒性比例了。现在它更倾向于一般意义上的战争受害者，我觉得稍微变得更模糊了一些。嗯，我觉得——从某种意义上说，我觉得它的显要程度在过去几十年里其实有所上升。自20世纪90年代以来确实如此。在我年轻的时候，我不觉得这是一件多么轰动的大事。所以，我想那是1990年代第二次世界大战五十周年纪念带来的影响吧。1990年代。90年代，然后我觉得，嗯——因为英国卷入了多场冲突，比如阿富汗
of british legion websites and things now they mentioned the world wars but not as much as they would have done 50 years ago and now it's kind of the victims of war generally i think it's sort of slightly more amorphous well i think i mean in a way i i think way, I think its prominence has risen over the past few decades. It definitely has since the 90s. I don't particularly remember it as a big thing when I was young. So I think it was the Second World War commemorations, wasn't it? In the 1990s. In the 1990s. 90s and then i think um because uh britain's been involved in a number of uh you know afghanistan
和伊拉克——它变成了一种让军队保持在公众视线中的方式。我认为其中绝对包含对受伤退伍军人的关怀，同时也有一个非常世俗的解释：世界大战在国家课程中占据了相当重的分量。因此，许多小学都会讲授两次世界大战的相关内容，而阵亡将士纪念日成了他们非常重要的教学工具。是的，再加上我们迎来了百年纪念。所以，是的。还有百年纪念。因此我觉得——我同意，这背后有深厚的文化原因，它已经成了一种国家层面的现象，第二次世界大战已经成为我们国家神话的一部分；但同时也有非常世俗的、制度层面的原因，使得它变得……
and iraq um it's become a way of keeping um the military in the public eye i think there's definitely an element of injured veterans and there's also a very mundane explanation which is that the world wars feature quite heavily on the national curriculum so primary a lot of primary schools will do elements of the two world wars and remembrance day becomes a really important kind of teaching tool for them yeah and then we've had the 100th anniversary so yeah and the 100th anniversary so there's sort of i agree i think there are deep cultural reasons it's become a national it's become certain second world war has become part of our national mythology but also they're almost quite mundane kind of institutional reasons why it's become
嗯，马克·伍德（Mark Wood）提出了这样一个问题：阵亡将士纪念日是一年中宗教色彩最浓的一天吗？嗯，我认为它的另一个方面是，英国已经成了一个多元文化社会，因此纯粹的基督教庆祝日已经不再像过去那样能够凝聚整个国家了，哪怕是圣诞节也做不到。然而阵亡将士纪念日——来自英联邦各地的人们都会参与其中。当然，现在人们极力强调——你知道的——一战中的锡克教士兵之类的，你可以用一种
well and this question from mark woodhouse is remembrance day the most religious day of the year um i i think another aspect of it is that that britain has become a multicultural society and so purely christian days of celebration no longer unite the nation in quite the way they did even christmas um whereas remembrance day you know people from across the Commonwealth they do and of course so much emphasis now on you know Sikh soldiers in World War I or something you can do it in
用行话来说就是“包容”的方式来处理它。我认为——而且很有说明意义的是，第一次世界大战墓地的圣像也是跨宗教的。如果你是基督徒，墓碑可以设计成十字架的形状，但也可以是犹太教的符号。
to use the jargon an inclusive way and I think it's you know and it's telling that the iconography of the First World War cemeteries are multi-faith the stones are designed that you can have a cross on if you're Christian, but say Jewish.
当纳粹占领比利时的时候，我觉得这太令人惊奇了……他们没有把墓地全砸烂。没有砸烂，而是原封不动地保留了。不，这很有趣，不是吗？据说当比利时光复时，甚至在战斗还在进行的时候，人们就已经在梅宁门（Menin Gate）吹响了冲锋号。是这样吗？
And I thought it was amazing that when the Nazis occupied Belgium... They didn't smash them all up. Didn't smash them up, left them alone. No, that is interesting, isn't it? And apparently when he got retaken, the last post was played at the Menin Gate, even as fighting was going on. Is that right?
因为当然他们每天都会在梅宁门吹响冲锋号，不是吗？除了战争期间。没错。太迷人了。然后他们一打回来，就立刻又开始吹冲锋号了。他们马上就开始吹了。是的。
Because of course they play the last post at the Menin Gate every day, don't they? Except during the war. Right. Fascinating. And then the moment they got back in, they started playing it again. They started doing it straight away. Yeah.
所以我们其实收到了一些关于阵亡将士纪念日的问题，我觉得真的很有意思……巴里·格罗根（Barry Grogan）有一个关于虞美人花的问题。他说：它是不是已经从一个纪念的象征变成了一种文化符号？我觉得他切中了要害，因为虞美人花——你选择戴还是不戴虞美人花，以及你戴什么颜色的虞美人花，现在已经变得非常具有政治色彩了。是的，这是一种文化现象。这确实有点像个文化符号。这并不是一种纯粹的文化。我不认为它是——我认为它——我不认为它是一种标志性符号——虽然某种程度上它确实是个标志，但你看，我觉得它
So we've got a couple of questions actually about Remembrance Day, which I think are really... So Barry Grogan has a question about the poppy. And he says, has it turned into more of a cultural symbol as opposed to a symbol of remembrance? And I think he's onto something because the poppy – your choice of whether or not to wear a poppy and what colour poppy you wear, it's now become a very kind of politicised. Yeah, it is a culture. It is a bit of a cultural thing. It's not a cultural. I don't think it is quite – I think it – I don't think it's it i don't think it's kind of signifier it is a signifier of sorts but you see i think it
甚至不像口罩那样具有强烈的符号属性。甚至不如面罩……不过白色的虞美人花确实是一个明确的标志，虽然你可能不知道……是的，白色的虞美人花绝对是……你看一个人戴着白色的虞美人花，你就会觉得他大概不读《每日快报》。嗯，我的意思是，我认为发生的另一件事是，人们对明确的“国家纪念活动”产生了一种紧张感。在把阵亡将士纪念日吹捧为一种国家庆典之后——当然，在法国和比利时，它仍然被称为“停战日”（Armistice Day），在美国被称为“退伍军人节”（Veterans Day）。所以我们并不是独一无二的。我们的一大特点可能是我们喜欢自认为是独一无二的，并且在自我鞭笞方面表现得非常狭隘。但其他国家也有阵亡将士纪念日的仪式。这没什么不寻常的。但在某些层面上，人们确实对任何带有强调国家哀悼特殊性的意味产生了紧张感。
not even as much as say masks face masks not even as much as face a white poppy is signified though you can't know that yeah white poppy definitely um you see a white poppy wearing you think he probably doesn't read the daily express well i think i mean one of the things i think also that's happened is that there has become a kind of nervousness about specifically national commemorations so having having kind of bigged up the idea of remembrance days as as as a national celebration but they do have i mean in france and belgium it's still it's called armistice day and the united states is called veterans day so we're not you. We one of the things that probably is unique about us is that we like to think we're unique and we can be very sort of parochial in our self-flagellation. But other people have Remembrance Day ceremonies. I mean, there's nothing unusual about it. there has become, you know, at certain levels, a nervousness about any sense that there should be something specific
是的，你只需要哀悼就行了。你应该哀悼每一个死去的人。是的，有趣的是，现在的足球俱乐部就是这么做的。他们在阵亡将士纪念日时会说这是为了所有战争的受害者。你会想，什么？所有的战争？百年战争吗？是的。第一次巴尔干战争？拜托，得了吧。现在，迈克尔·伍德（Michael Wood）有一个非常棒的问题——正如你对迈克尔·伍德的期待那样，
about national mourning. Yeah, you should just mourn. You should mourn everybody who dies. Yeah, well, this is what football clubs now do, interestingly. They now say the victims of all wars in their Remembrance Day. And you sort of think, what, all wars? A hundred years war? Yeah. The first Balkan war? mean come on yeah um now Michael Wood has a really good question um as you would
他是节目的老朋友，本身就是一位伟大的历史学家——他问道：“我们何时以及如何才能刻意遗忘这些战争，以便我们能够向前看？”这其实是个非常深刻的问题。所以，你知道的，在24世纪，人们还会纪念第一次世界大战吗？你不得不说不会。嗯，他说：我不确定，我不确定这……是那个历史学家迈克尔·伍德吗？哦，真的吗？也许是另一个迈克尔·伍德？我们有两个叫迈克尔·伍德的节目老朋友，对吧？确实如此。嗯，这种情况发生时——他括号里写道：“就像我们在拿破仑战争之后做的那样，等等。”但不同的是，你知道的，正如我们在节目开始时所说的那样，我们并没有以这种方式纪念拿破仑战争。
expect from Michael Wood friend of the show great historian in his own right um he says when and how will we deliberately forget these wars so we can move on and actually that's a really good question so you know in the 24th century will people still be remembering the first world war you'd have to say no well he he says i'm not sure i'm not i'm not sure it's uh michael wood the historian oh really another michael wood maybe i'm a friend of the show that also we do we have two michael wood friends of the show don't we it's true um it happened he puts in brackets as we did after the napoleonic wars etc but the difference is that you know as we said at the beginning of the show, we didn't commemorate the Napoleonic Wars in this way.
我的意思是，这是全新的。对于20世纪来说，这是一种以前从未做过的事情。但是，汤姆，你觉得我们什么时候会停止谈论世界大战？还是说你觉得永远不会？好吧，我不知道，因为我们没有先例可循。你知道的，我们发明了一种仪式。我们发明了一种仪式。古希腊人是什么时候停止谈论波斯战争的？我的意思是，他们从来没有停止谈论过。不，他们从没有，他们总是在喋喋不休地谈论。但那稍微有些
Yeah. I mean, this is new. For the 20th century, this is something that had not been done before. But when would you stop talking about the World Wars, Tom? Or do you think never? Well, I don't know, because we don't have any guidance you know we've invented a ritual we've invented a ritual when did the greeks stop talking about the persian wars i mean they never stopped talking about it no they never they never always going on about it but that's slightly
不同，不是吗？那是仪式。所以，纪念仪式的传统——伯里克利（Pericles）在其中发表了演讲的那种悼念仪式——在雅典不再是一个独立民主国家时就结束了。没错。因为这与公民身份紧密相连。
different isn't it it's the rituals so the the rituals of um a commemoration that in which pericli gave his speech ended when a when Athens ceased to be an independent democracy. Right. Because it's bound up with civic identity. for people to contemplate death and bereavement and suffering in a way that in general our public cultural life does not provide opportunities for we've become squeamish about it in a way that previous generations didn't and i think that the decline of institutional religion has left a kind of gap in the market that the remembrance day celebrations fills i'm sure that's true i also think there's another dimension which is that it it has become a celebration of the idea of sacrifice
……让人们以一种我们的公共文化生活通常不提供机会的方式去思考死亡、丧亲和痛苦。我们对此变得过分敏感了，而前几代人并非如此。我认为制度化宗教的衰落留下了某种市场空白，而阵亡将士纪念日的庆典恰好填补了这一空白。我确信这是真的。我还认为有另一个维度的原因，那就是它已经变成了对牺牲、责任等概念的一种礼赞。你不这么认为吗？所以这里有一种细微的观念，认为他们为国家献出了生命，特别是对那些从一战和二战角度来思考它的人来说，这关乎那些将集体利益、更大利益置于个人之上的人。对此我不太确信。
and duty and so on. Do you not think? So there's this slight idea of they gave their lives for their country, especially for people who think about it in terms of particularly the First and Second World Wars, that it's about people who put the collective, the greater good above individual. I'm not sure about that.
我确信。我绝对认为这正关于此。因为你会想到《黑爵士》（Blackadder）里的桥段，你会想到……但人们在过阵亡将士纪念日时并不是在想那些，对吧？我认为“咬紧牙关坚持到底”（stiff upper lips）、服务精神、责任感、担当，
I do. I think it's absolutely about that. Because you think of the Blackadder stuff, you think about the... But people aren't thinking about that when Remembrance Day, are they? I think the idea of stiff upper lips, of service, of duty, of responsibility,
以及报名为国王和国家尽自己的一份力的精神，我不认为……我认为绝大多数人——非常多的人非常珍视这一点，但我认为同样有非常多的人觉得这多少有点荒谬。荒谬？是的，我确实这么觉得。汤姆·霍兰。
of signing up to do your bit for king and country, I don't think that... I think large... Lots and lots of people hold that very dear, but I think lots and lots of people see it as faintly risible. Risible? Yeah, I do. Tom Holland.
你花在宣传《卫报》周六版上的时间太多了。而你在英格兰腹地（Middle England）待得太久了。我确实认为，自20世纪60年代以来，责任和担当的理念一直是讽刺和嘲弄的对象。顺便说一句，我正在把这一切都记下来，准备写一篇关于你拒绝佩戴虞美人花的文章。作者是一位顶级在线历史学家。
You spent too much time promoting that Guardian Saturday section. And you spent too long in Middle England. I do think, you know, ever since the 60s, the idea of duty and responsibility have been the subject of satire and mockery. I'm noting all this down, by the way, for that article about your refusal to wear the poppy. By top and on historian.
是的。我可没有拒绝佩戴虞美人花。我只是从来没戴过。今天在布里克斯顿街头被拍到的画面，11月11日。汤姆·霍兰去买牛奶，同时进行着挑衅性的拒绝。不，我会在读《园丁》（The Gardener）。哦，对，太棒了。你当然会读。
Yeah. I don't refuse to wear the poppy. I just never have. Photographed on the streets of Brixton today, the 11th of November. Tom Holland goes to buy milk while defiantly refusing. No, I'll be reading The Gardener. Oh, yeah, very good. Of course you will.
对。好吧。我觉得我们已经把自己说到了濒临被“取消”的边缘。不过不是互相取消，而是我们要被彼此的竞争受众给取消了。是的，完全如此。这本该如此。……濒临被取消的边缘，而是互相取消，也就是我跟我的竞争受众。是的，完全如此。这本该如此。所以，是的，我认为阵亡将士纪念日——我同意你的看法，我认为它具有神圣的意义。当和平纪念碑遭到袭击时，人们的反应充分说明了这一点——远比——我们讨论过丘吉尔的雕像，但远比
Yeah. Right. I think we've talked ourselves to the brink of cancellation. But of cancelling each other. We're going to be cancelled by rival constituencies. Yeah, exactly. That's as it should be. brink of cancellation but of canceling each other which is my rival constituency yeah exactly um yeah that's as it should be so yes i think remembrance day i agree with you i think it is a sacred i think it does have a sacred meaning you see that in people's reaction when the cenotaph is attacked uh far more than i mean we've talked about the statue of churchill but far more
丘吉尔的雕像更甚，和平纪念碑感觉像是这座岛上仅存的一处神圣空间，以一种奇怪的方式，难道不是吗？是的，我想是的，除了巨石阵的隧道之外……除此以外，是的。不，我觉得你是对的，我认为——我不想这么说，但我知道我……你刚才想说什么？我本来想说……你现在要说出来了吗？好吧，我本来想说，在英国所有的象征中，那是遭到破坏会让人心痛得最深的象征。我有点犹豫要不要说出来，以免这会激发某些恐怖组织之类去把它炸了。但我认为它
than the statue of churchill the sanitar feels like the ones the one sacred space on this island actually in a weird way isn't it yeah i think it's the apart from the stonehenge tunnel apart from that yes no i think you're right i think that that um i don't want to say it but i mean i know I... What were you going to say? I was going to say... You're going to say it now? Well, I was going to say that of all the symbols of Britain, that is the one that I think its destruction would most wound. And I'm kind of hesitant to say it in case this then inspires some terrorist group or something to blow it up but I think it
具有一种情感共鸣：因为它是为所有人而设的，因为它是空置的，因为它不关乎伟人，而是关乎整个国家，甚至从根本上说它甚至不只关乎国家，而是关乎死亡与痛苦是客观存在的这一事实。是的。这——是的，它确实具有一种神圣的品质，我认为。
it has a kind of emotional resonance that because it's for everyone and because it is empty and because it's not about great men it's about the entirety of the nation but it's not even ultimately about the nation it's about the fact that death and suffering happens. Yeah. That, yeah, it does have a kind of sacred quality, I think.
是的，汤姆，我完全同意你的看法。我认为这是一个充满悲伤和沉思的地方，以及所有诸如此类的感受。这赋予了它远远超其他一切的地位。当我们漫步观察那些雕像时，你说那是唯一一个人们会驻足、凭吊、摆放花圈的地方。所以它依然具有强大的力量。
Yeah, I agree with you completely, Tom. I think it's a place of grief and of contemplation and all these kinds of things. And that does give it a status well beyond anything else. When we did our walk looking at the statues, you said that was the one place that people were stopping, were standing by, that there were wreaths there. And so it still has its power.
确实如此。历经一个世纪。好了。我们要去写各自打擂台的文章了。但实际上，我们真的要走了。汤姆，你确实启发了我。我要去重新阅读《园丁》了。我想其他人也应该去读读。
It absolutely does. A century on. Right. We're off to go and write our rival articles. But actually, we're really off to go. You have actually inspired me, Tom. I am going to go and reread The Gardener. And I think everybody else should.
这是一篇精彩的短篇小说。我们以此开篇，也将以此结束。而且你必须一直读到最后，因为直到最后一刻你才会体会到那种强烈的震撼。好的。我们下次见。谢谢收听。
It's a brilliant short story. We started with it. We'll end with it. And you have to read it right to the end because it's not until the end that you get the full punch. All right. We will see you next time. Thanks for listening.
再见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。如需获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。